[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will be on the call
he's got the afc title game westwood won
busy guy
he was uh the uh yet uh yes yes
nets play-by-play voice last night of
course all season long
as he got a chance to see the nets and
the cavs i guess the nets fully
assembled with uh kyrie back
you want to start with football you want
to start with the game last night ayan
hey uh dan before we start could i just
tell you how i became a new york arrows
fan
yes yes indoor soccer league yeah
became such a huge part of my life steve
jungle
was an icon yeah and i just couldn't get
enough of it
i consumed it every day 24 7.
and it lives with me today that's all i
wanted to know i i i wish i chatted with
you
yeah i wish you well thank you all the
best this was like a quasi-human moment
that we just said thank you
are you preparing for both quarterbacks
you know so as a play-by-play guy you
know we hear defenses got to prepare for
both quarterbacks
are you prepared for chad heny and
patrick mahomes this weekend
dan this is this is why you're the best
interviewer in the business
nobody has ever asked me are you
prepared for chad henny
do you have your call straight anything
can happen
let's go get the ad-libs moving
i'm i'm ready either way i feel very
comfortable
uh that that i can handle it if if it is
henny
i'll make the adjustment dad you're pro
you're a pro's pro
you're a pros pro but when you prepare
for
these games how important is it that you
you know you get the access to these
players or these coaches and and you
know
by doing this remotely trying to get
access how difficult is that
that's probably been the strangest part
of the season
the lack of interaction not just with
players and coaches that were accustomed
to doing the network games but
each other we did not have one
production meeting in person
everything was done virtually and you
make the most of that when you can and
you do have people's attention you also
see people in some rather strange setups
i must admit that that throws you a bit
when you get a little deeper
inside like me for right now i'm i'm not
where you think i
am you know i i have to do what i have
to do i
i get a rental in wyoming and this is
this is what we're doing for this season
uh you don't have pants on i don't
i don't but no you nailed it the
access or lack thereof yes
there's definitely a part of the
broadcast that suffered because of it
but you find other ways and even on
these zoom calls you
you figure out a way to connect with a
player and and find
something that's a little different that
might create a unique answer that you
can use
on the air but we we did not go to one
facility
the entire season and our schedule was
very strict
get to the city test wait for your test
result
in your room until you get it and then
even then very limited access to to
other people
what's on the bookshelf back there
this uh this is my wife's office i have
no idea well you've got bobble heads
there you got a basket yes
hold on hold on i have a dress designer
dave what what do we got going here dan
wants to know
i'll figure it out later okay i'm just
curious you don't even know what's
behind you
he's uh iron eagle or ian eigel the uh
yes network uh play-by-play voice for
the uh that have you been called that
haven't you before oh very much i've
been called
ian igle i've been called ian iagley
i've been called iron eagle i've been
called yon
eagle i've been called many things that
i can't even say
on on your family-friendly show at what
point uh
last night did you realize that uh the
nets might be in trouble against the
pesky cavaliers
uh when colin sexton had a out-of-body
experience didn't you say
colin sexton is not human
yes and and i want to make sure
everybody understands that that's
incorrect that that is not a criticism
that is applauded i'm saying that he's
gone beyond what
we thought was humanly capable so i hope
he takes that as a positive that's
that's what it was meant as yeah they
they ran out of gas
clearly obviously sexton hits a three at
the end of regulation
uh the nets can't convert there's a foul
call that gets overturned but a jump
ball
knocked to the back court they go to
overtime sexton starts to heat up
and then as we saw uh he took over
in the second ot it's one game we all
want
instant gratification as we know in life
people love instant coffee
and instant dating this is going to take
a little bit of time
for for things to gel and mesh but boy
is it going to be entertaining and fun
along the way
do you have answers do you care about
answers from kyrie irving
yeah i think the the concern for me
would be if he's garnering
joy from this that that to me is
is the real question he didn't show a
whole lot of emotion in the game and
look i'm not going to
play psychiatrist i can only see what i
see i'm not even at the game
you know let's let's face facts i'm
watching it from a screen
at barclay center when the game is in
cleveland so you want to talk about
lacking nuance
you're getting no nuance you can only
see what they show you
but what i could gather was the first
time he really emoted
was when that offensive foul was called
on him and then you saw some of the
facial expressions
he's definitely going through some stuff
right now and
the biggest key is that he gets through
that and from a team standpoint
they need someone that is fully
committed and all in and if there's some
things happening in his private life
that are affecting that
then he's gonna have to take care of
that before the team can really turn the
page and focus on
winning a championship when you do
play-by-play how much of it
is focused on the monitor as opposed to
watching the game itself yeah nfl
i've probably leaned more towards the
monitor
over the last couple of years than i had
in previous years
uh trying to make sure that i'm talking
to pictures so i would say
it's in that 50 50 range for
nfl for nba
i'm i was normally under normal
circumstances i was 70
30 live action 30 off the monitor
and right now we're 100
basically even the home games because
you're high up
i find myself cheating towards the
monitor more than i ever did
when i was courtside just to make sure
that
my eyes are matching what i think i'm
seeing on the court
uh it's it's definitely been an
adjustment look nobody
at home probably cares and nor should
they
it's the play-by-play person's challenge
and you've gotta
figure it out in your own way have you
ever stopped
talking while just watching a play like
you almost forget that you're supposed
to be calling the play
that you're watching yeah i would say
now more than ever that part
actually creeps into your head because
you're not there
there's the moment of detachment that
you feel
that man i i'm just watching this like
everybody else but you have to
call it i've been pretty fortunate that
i've maintained the running commentary
but there have been a few moments where
my normal muscle memory has not kicked
in of what i'm seeing
synthesizing the information and
spitting it out
i would say this year dan in even a
truncated season
i probably made two or three
mistakes on identification
and i went through maybe a 10-year
stretch where i made
zero mistakes i did on identification
just based on
your brain taking in the information
processing it
thinking you saw something and then
questioning for a moment
if you did how much do you follow social
media
after a game you've done i do have a
burner account
i'll i'll be the first to admit that uh
it's
uh todd fritz 11. if you want to
follow me on twitter
uh i i follow a little bit i definitely
have people that send me things so i
i know what's happening i'm aware of
what's being talked about well last time
you got roughed up
oh man uh nfl games i would say i
i take a day off after the game
i i just learned probably two years ago
that that would maintain my sanity i i
must say
i don't get it as bad as others so i'm
certainly not in a position to complain
i i try to bring across a affable
quality dan
of course that resonates it is evident
right now
i'm saying please don't twitter world
don't
don't kill me who's the play-by-play
voice that you want to fight
right now yeah just if i had to take on
one play-by-play voice right now
yeah that's a great
could you take joe buck you know
joe joe's obviously bigger than me um
i think i think i could surprise joe
in the lower extremity areas that he may
not be anticipating
that i would attack
eagle wants a piece of joe buck
blow the blinds
all below the waist yes yeah lay off
the money maker joe stay away from the
face uh what advice did you give your
son when he did the nfl game on
nickelodeon
uh i i did not want to inundate him so i
just gave him
three pieces of advice that i thought
could help him in the broadcast
one i said you have to have command
when this game goes on the air people
have to realize
that this is unique this is different
and it's gonna start with you it's gonna
emanate
from you if you set the tone early then
people will get it
two you have to be a really good point
guard a traffic cop
get everybody involved if you sense that
somebody
isn't getting a touch get them a touch
and then three
you must have fun the whole point of the
broadcast is to have fun and if that's
not coming across on the air if you guys
aren't laughing if you're not enjoying
each other's company then this thing is
not going to work
and he he checked every box i was really
really impressed with how he handled
himself he did a great job and
you know i thought that uh nate burleson
did a wonderful job as well
just he's a star yeah he is a true
television superstar
yeah well it's great to talk to you and
uh you too good luck now you don't
do you get to go to kansas city or are
you staying at home for the game
no kansas city i do travel oh you do so
i will be in kansas city and
i should mention in the nfl i did travel
the entire
season and that was odd like airports
are
empty for the most part tsa you're
getting through
for me sometimes 45 seconds and people
have been very respectful
of other people's space normally it was
the herd mentality
when they did the boarding process now
people lay back
and wait so it's been nice it's been a
nice change
yeah i wasn't going to uh listen to the
game or watch the game but now that i've
spoken to you i'm going to uh i'm going
to listen to
i'm going to stay in my car and listen
to westwood 1. and i'm not going to
watch it
this is why we do the the interviews i
want you to promotion
i want you to paint the picture for me i
am i am going to paint the word picture
and the whole time i'm going to be
thinking about fighting joe buck
and his lower extremities are you doing
that's the lord because if you're not
doing the super bowl then i'm not going
to be
i'm not going to be watching i will be
at the super bowl i will be
in a secondary host role and i will also
be
in a jose ocendo type
setup wait how did joseo kendo that's a
deep reference here
deep reference i have to be ready for a
number of roles
okay first what's needed in the
situation
are you an understudy to gym nance at
the super bowl
were you a seinfeld viewer yeah
yeah uh so bette midler's understudy
it didn't go that way rochelle rochelle
rochelle rochelle i i didn't i don't
want to
i don't want to say that it's it's
comparative to that but it
it might be so i don't want to confirm
that but i'm certainly not going to deny
it
and nance knows your name right
i think so okay
but if nance no shows you are calling
the super bowl
[Laughter]
uh we're counting on you this weekend
but wait are you doing the nets game on
friday
i am against the cavaliers i am oh my
god
colin sexton is not human
hold on let me write that okay i should
use that
thank you bud see you there that's uh
ian eigel or iron eagle
the uh nets play by play voice also does
uh nfl on cbs and westwood one
got a lot of jobs